improve your django skills by building a
digital resume website bobby stearman
teaches this course he provides a free
resume website template and will teach
you how to program the back end using
django hey everyone it's bobby from
dudecoding here and i've put this course
together today because if you're
anything like me you've applied for
numerous developer roles over the years
and you've been successful some of the
time but you've missed out on most now
this is because there are so many
talented developers out there so you
must stand out in a crowd it's
absolutely paramount that you do so i'll
show you today how to digitize your
resume using django now the reason we're
using django is twofold firstly with
django you have a built-in admin page
which allows you to create read update
delete objects
so this will avoid the need to
update the source code in your project
so we can add objects in the admin page
and it gets rendered straight into the
html which is fantastic and secondly it
gives us a chance to
polish up on our django skills so we
will be firstly
finding a template we've got a template
that you can download for free we'll be
then
creating a django project we'll be
building out the back end the front end
and then we'll be stringing it all
together so this will take just over an
hour so let's jump straight into it
[Music]
this is the template that we're going to
be using so this has been designed by
james granger design a colleague of mine
um
he's fantastic he's put this together
we're not charging anybody you can
access this template in our github
repository which is github.com bobby
dash decoding
dig coding underscore resume underscore
template so decoding resume template
like i say completely free all you need
to do is clone a repository and you will
have access to it i will show you today
how to then
string that template into a django
project okay
this is what the template looks like at
the very top here you have an avatar you
have a bio or it will be a bio
we've then got a link to download a
resume so we'll need a pdf version of
your resume and we'll attach that to a
user profile we have key skills coding
skills with a slide bar
we have some certificates that we can
scroll through
we have portfolio section
we have a testimonial section and we
also have recent posts
that's the index page we have a
portfolio list view
okay
we have a blog list view which is almost
the same and a contact page the
portfolio and blog pages will also have
detailed pages as well and they will be
rendered to the front end with a rich
text editor which we will also add to
django admin so what we add in a rich
text editor will be rendered directly as
it's
seen in admin to the front end which is
fantastic like i say we will be creating
objects in django admin without the need
to change the source code for the
project
okay and this contact us form allows
potential employers to contact you add
the name email and a message and submit
great so that is the template that is
what we will be building today in django
so
first thing that we need to do is
use a text editor
i'll be using visual code studio today
and this is opened up in development so
the first thing i've got a terminal open
here as well first thing that we need to
do
is create a virtual environment now i'm
using a virtual environment wrapper so i
can
just use the command make virtual env
and we will call this
resume
demo okay and that will go ahead and it
will create a virtual environment on my
machine and it will fire it up the
reason i know it's fired up is because
we've got this in brackets here so
resume demo
so now that's there we now need to
we have now have access to pip
so we can pip install
django
we'll also pip install
pillow
and we'll also pip install um django
ck
editor
okay they're the three that we will need
straight off the bat okay once that's
finished installing all of that we will
then start a django project
and we will call it again same as the
virtual environment we'll call this
resume demo okay
don't worry if you have this come up
it's just telling you that you need to
update pip just simply
paste that in there
bob's your uncle that's installed the
latest version of pip so we're all good
to go right so now we need to cd no we
don't we need to start a project so
because we've installed django we can
now access django admin
and
we say start project and we'll call this
resume
demo okay that will start project we can
now cd into
resume
demo
there we have it and let's open that up
in my
browser here
there we have it it's there do you know
what let's open up a new
open a
folder development we'll just open that
up here so we haven't got
all of the other stuff
let's open up terminal
and we will go work on
again that's another command from a
virtual emv wrapper
so we've got these pop-ups so we'll call
we'll run
resume demo well we've got the
virtual envy up and running again and
this is the project directory so when
you um
start a new project you get the
manage.py file and then you'll also have
the resume
resume demo directory with the dunder
init file we've got ascii settings urls
and
um whiskey
okay so what we'll do now we can access
the manage.py what we can do we can
python
manage dot py
will start an app and we'll call this
main
okay
and
now we will go about so what i'm
what i'm going to do is i'm going to be
referencing my other screen because i've
built this project in am
previously just to make sure it all
works and it speeds things up rather
than having to watch me do typos and and
have to debug all of my code so i'm
going to move this through
from a from another screen copy and
pasting it across so it's nice and
smooth and we aren't going to be too
clunky
so the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to open up settings.py
okay and this is what it looks like when
you first
install the django project so right at
the top here
import os
so that allows us to access the
operating system this project will
require the use of static files so and
the reason we have os is because we'll
be using that in a second to
join the base directory to the new
static file directories
we have this is the base dir which will
be referencing that's the secret key
now in a production environment you
would secure that maybe in an env of
some sort but we won't in this tutorial
debug is true allowed host is all good
what we need to do is we need to add
main
into our installed apps we also
need to add ck
editor
there we go
that will allow us to use a rich text
editor in the admin page
middleware we don't need any middleware
that i know of just double check
no we don't but we will
be adding a context processor
so the context processor will go in here
processors.py
and the context process py
will be looking like this so we'll be um
importing the user model here so that's
the built-in user model and we'll be
just adding um a keyword argument called
me
to the context process and it'll all
come
you'll understand what's happening soon
enough uh we're going to settings.py we
can now add that context processor to
the
context processor here
so we'll have
resume
demo
there's dot context processors dot
project context and we don't need that
last one there
okay so now this
um context here so this keyword me will
be accessible in the templates that
we're building out later on in this demo
so whiskey application we don't need to
do anything there we're just going to
use the built-in sqlite 3 database now
you could upgrade that to post sql or
mysql but we won't in this
so when we make the migrations there'll
be a db sq light
uh file that appears but don't worry too
much about that
we'll change the
en to gb
and what we'll then do is we will add
the static
files
does and the static route the media
route and what have you
okay so i won't go through what we're
trying to do here but essentially
we need to access static files so static
files are like css files javascript
files and and and images that just don't
change right so they sit in a static
directory we will be accessing them
things like logos things like cascading
style sheets so these settings here
allow us to or it tells the system where
those directories are going to be and
how they're going to be managed okay
so that is it we don't need to do
anything else to settings but we do need
another file file in here called urls.py
oh it's already in there sorry
um
yeah we don't need that so i'm getting
carried away so in the urls um py file
i will then
copy all of this across so we need to
add
include to path
we need to bring in settings from
django.conf and we need static from
conf.urls.static
and we will be adding the path
mains.url so we haven't even created
that file yet but we'll do that in a
second
but we're adding this to the url pattern
so all of the urls in the main.urls file
that we'll create in a second
will then become part of our url
patterns okay we could call it main
namespace equals main so that's what
we'll call it in the app in a few
seconds
and then we've got this here
so
if settings.debug we then add
the static url
and a static route to the url patterns
and we also do it the same for media url
and media root so in development
environment we will simply have a static
directory
in here
and we'll have a media
it'll be called media file so as we save
an avatar or an image it will add a
directory and i'll add the image or the
file to the directory within the media
files directory okay so that is the urls
there
main what we need to do is straight away
we need
urls.py right so we will
have that file
and we will create that we'll be
referencing views that we haven't
created yet but we'll add it in there
anyway
okay and the reason we're doing that is
because
trying to do this in in in a good order
normally you would add this after you
create the views and you wouldn't create
the views until you added the models but
we're referencing this file in this
urls.py file so um we're bringing in
path and views okay which we haven't
created yet the app name is main okay
in fact what we could do because we
might need to make some migrations
before we do this so i will
uh comment those out
okay because we haven't we haven't
created those yet anyway so we'll start
in order so where you start with you
start with models okay
so models
models are um translate to
um
database tables okay
so um
we will create a model uh the name
becomes the table name and fields become
the rows sorry the columns and then for
each object that we save becomes each
row in that table so that's basically
what a um django model represents copy
and we'll paste okay
so
bringing in models and we're bringing in
the built-in user model that is in
contrib or models we need that because
we're going to extend that for the
user profile
okay
we'll be extending it using something
called signals but we'll go through that
in a second we then bring in sluggify
because we need a slug for our blog and
our portfolio we're then bringing in ck
editor so this is django ck editor it's
a rich text field so this we can add
this rich text field to the blog and
portfolio
so let's create a skill
model
we have a meta class
and i always add these
not necessarily needed by default it
will it will pluralize the name
but i add it in there anyway it's not
the end of the world okay so name equals
this is a char field
so these will be the skills so we're
gonna go back in here
these will be these skills here okay
this is what we're trying to replicate
so we want coding skills and we want key
skills okay
so we've got name of the of the skill
the score so if this was a key skill or
sorry a coding skill we'd want to score
it because we want the sliding bars
on here to
represent 95 or 80 percent of the skill
or the not your expertise in a certain
skill we then have an image the reason
we've got an image or file field because
this is an svg so these images here are
svgs so for each key skill
we want an image okay so we'll do that
and then is key skill which is a boolean
so it's true or false so if this is true
then this
object would represent a key skill if
it's false it would represent a coding
skill so we then have a
string function and it just returns
self.name okay so that's our skill model
we then have a user profile so this is
what extends the built-in user model
that's why we've got a one-to-one field
here
on delete cascade will only be be
producing or creating one user profile
so that would be us as a super user we
have an avatar which is an image field
this is why we brought in
pillow
upload two and this will create a
directory in media files called avatar
and when we save a file in there that is
where that avatar will go we've got a
title a bio so the idea of a bio is this
bit here so that will appear there when
we add it to the templates
we then have skills which is many to
many
okay so it would be many to many of
these skills here
uh and then we have a cv which is a five
field this will be uploaded to a cv cv
directory so each time you update your
cv on your paper copy you'll update this
or upload it to this field here and it
will save the new copy in the directory
and then the string function method here
just
returns first name and last name of
their user model
we then got a contact profile
which is a timestamp which that gets
added automatically okay so it's a date
time field then a name email message so
if we look back on here if we're going
to contact
name email message that's what we're
trying to capture here
testimonial
we have a thumbnail this is for the
testimonial on home
so what we're trying to do is just
replicate all of these elements right so
this is we need a thumbnail we need a
in here we're going to have uh the name
of the person who's actually given a
testimonial and the role and then we
have the quote itself so in here we've
got name roll quote and is active we're
adding this is active boolean field to
all of these models or the testimonial
the the portfolio in the blog because
although we want to add a testimonial we
want to be able to quickly switch it on
and off so if it's inactive we don't
want it to be shown up on the website so
that's why we've got an active field
there
media
so the reason we're doing this is
because if we can add an image to a
media
model that image gets saved into
the media file
the media directory within the media
files directory and we then have access
to that url when we're creating the rich
text editor image
it'll all make sense a little bit later
but um that's just an easy way of
accessing static files in a template um
when we're messing around in admin which
i'll show you what that means soon
so is image the reason why this because
we're doing this is because you could
technically add a url here
um for a video and then if this was a
false it would be a video url it's safe
saving huge
mp4s in your database
save function so um
so if the url is blank then sorry if
sorry self url is
not blank then is image becomes false
okay so programmatically adjust this is
image depending on the url field
and then we've got a portfolio
so a date so this is the date in which
the the
job was done name description body so
this is important this is the rich text
field this is what
this is the rich text editor that will
be updating in the admin page what you
see is what you get rendered in html or
in the browser so that is really
important that you have that there so
rich text field there is being
referenced right at the top of the page
here so it's part of ck editor dot
fields
then got an image which would be the
thumbnail if you like gets uploaded to
portfolio
but then got a slug which is a slug
field and is active see the slug field
is populated here with the save method
so
if not self id so basically if it's a
new new object we sluggify the self.name
which what it does it
all of the uh the the characters become
lower case and all spaces are then
underscored so it becomes a slug
we've then got the get absolute url
here so it's portfolio slugs
we do exactly the same for blog okay so
blog is basically the same as portfolio
then lastly we've got certificate which
is a date name title description is
active nothing fancy going on in in
certificate there so that's models
what we'll then do we will register
all of those into our admin
so we can access them this is
one of the most important parts of it we
want to be able to access all of those
models in our admin page
okay so what we're doing we're importing
all of them from dot models all of the
new models here and then we're using a
decorator admin.register
we're registering the user profile but
then we're adding a class under that
called user profile admin what this does
this will allow us to display
this will allow us to display um the
fields that we want in the admin page
okay so let's display id user we've then
got timestamp name and then also on here
we've got read-only fields so the slug
we cannot change we don't really want to
be changing that because a slug could be
used you could send a blog link
you could have a backlink somewhere for
a blog page and you don't really want to
be changing the slug because then that
link becomes inactive so when the slug
is produced
that remains the same no matter what so
we have a read-only field so that's
what's going on in admin
we then want a way of creating the user
profile using signals so we'll go in
main new file
signals dot py
and we will add
this code to signals
what it's doing it's
import and post save the built-in user
model
import and receiver which is a decorator
and then we're bringing in the user
profile which we just created now what
this signal is it's a receiver so when
a
object is created when a user object is
created it fires a signal to this
signal's p um
py file there's a receiver that picks up
that signal
and then
this function is called right so it's
create profile so we bring in as
keywords
um
sorry argument sender instance created
and then some keyword arguments so if
created so if the user object is created
then we want to create user profile
and that will become
userprofile.objects.create and then the
user which is a one-to-one field if you
remember equals the instance
that is what's going to be used to
create the user profile so when we
create a super user uh in a few moments
that user will be created the signal
will be fired this will receive the
signal bob's your uncle will have a user
profile
but we need to wire this signals.py file
in to the apps.py and how we do that is
we
uh overwrite the ready
method
i am right
here we just haven't
bought himself
brilliant okay and then we need to
import
main
dot
signals
that's all we need to do so when this
will fire up the app itself the main app
and it will just say right when ready
then we need to bring in signals and now
these signals will all work so
when the when the app is running signals
is all
working okay
what we then need to do is create some
model forms so or a model form for our
contact form
forms dot py
oh have i added the oh i have that's
fine
and what we'll do go in forms
oh
let's delete
delete that
when i go in here
and we want a new file not a new
directory so
forms dot py
paste everything in oh sorry i do
apologize copy
and paste
importing forms and we're also importing
contact profile which is the model that
we made in the models.py file so this
will be a model form okay
so we'll be
we don't actually need these i never
took these out when i was playing
earlier
actually it's worthwhile showing you
so let's save that so
this is a model form and this represents
a form against the model that we just
created contact form so what you need to
do is we you need to create these
variables one for each field that we
want in the form itself okay so we've
got name and then we want to this here
is the representation of
uh this is what will be rendered
in the html on the front end okay
so forms this is a character field max
length equals 100 so the reason that's
100 is because in the models file
where is it let's go into contacts
there we go
name max length 100 okay
so that's why we're doing that
we then have required trees so this is a
field that is true so this will render
an input element and it will be required
true okay
widget equals forms dot text input so
this is a text so the input will be
type equals text
then we have some attributes so we have
a placeholder and in this case it will
be star which will be rendered in the
actual input itself would be start full
name dot dot and then you can add class
now we don't actually need class if you
were to buy a template the forms that
you have in the template may have
certain classes this is where you would
add those classes to make sure that the
form that gets rendered on the front end
is exactly the same as what is in your
template okay so that's what we've got
there we don't actually need them
because we're not using form control in
our template so i'll remove them
so we've got email email field max
length is 254 which is completely
standard for an email field and then
we've got a placeholder we then got a
message now this is slightly different
it's not a text input it's a text area
now we want rows six now this all
depends on your template in my template
we have six rows okay so that's why
we've got row six
but you might have ten or whatever
placeholder is message then we have a
class meta model which this represents
is contact profile and the fields that
we want to render is name email message
that is our forms.py file
then what we need to do is add our views
so
let me copy all of that
i'll go in here
in our views dot py file and i'll dump
them all in there
okay so right at the top here
i've added import messages the reason we
want import messages is when a form
when a form is valid and when a form is
saved we will then want to render a
message so that the message pops up and
says thank you very much for submitting
the form or what have you so i'm
bringing in messages to do that
from dot models import and then we want
to import all of these different models
from django.views import generic we're
going to be using the generic views
template view list view form view so on
and so forth they're great these
built-in form views they're all
class-based views but they're they're
built specifically for
um tasks that happen regularly so for
instance a list view you're rendering a
list of objects so it just does all the
hard graft in the background so you've
got you can render
you you can render a a web page they say
a form view with only two or three lines
of code
which is great you can also do function
based views but i like to use these
built-in built-in views they're
fantastic
so we've got index view this will be our
home page okay so we're using
generic.templateview so we need we
in a template view you need to add the
template name so what name what template
are we using to render this view in this
case it's going to be main index so what
we'll do is we need a directory in main
called
templates
and within that directory we need
another one called
main
okay
within there
that is where we will add our templates
we'll do that shortly we don't need to
do that just yet
we then call the method get context data
um and we call a super call there and
then context we can then add keywords to
context here so testimonials so we want
testimonials certificates blogs and
portfolio these are objects so these are
um
these will be added to context and we
can reference them in templates uh so
that we can actually render a list and
do a for loop using uh template filters
and things like that
so we're calling testimonial objects and
we're filtering everything where is
active equals true this is where that
field in models comes in really handy
so
in testimonial okay isaac
is active defaults to true but if in
admin we click it to be untrue or false
then it will not appear
in the context because we're filtering
out everything that's
sorry filtering out everything that's
untrue so is active equals true so only
true
objects
live objects active objects we then have
certificates same again blog same again
portfolio same again and then we're
adding those keywords to context and
then we return context so now in index
we can reference
testimonials and that will be a list of
objects that we can
render
contact view this is a form view so you
name the template
you name the form class and then a
success url this is where the user will
be redirected when the form is valid so
we then call the
form valid method
password self and form so this is the
form which we're passing through which
is a contact form
form.save so we save the form instance
and then we send this message here which
is message.success
and the text is thank you we will be in
touch soon and that is what will be
shown on the front end
we then have a portfolio view which is a
list view the model is portfolio you do
have to have a page name by so this will
only show 10 or the first 10 objects
and then the template name the query set
what we're doing there is we're
filtering the query set is active true
okay so only true portfolios
detail view
same again exact except for and this
will be the slug so we'll add this in
the url so it will show the detail so
it'll show the object that has the slug
in the url itself
blog view identical to the portfolio
view and the blog detail view is
identical to the portfolio detail view
the only difference is we're looking at
different html files okay so they are
the views we will save that
just looking at my
what we have not done is we have not
created a requirements
file so we will go pip freeze
requirements
dot txt
and that's just created this so these
are all the requirements for the project
we've got django like you can see django
ck editor we've got pillow because we're
messing around with images
and that's all the um requirements happy
days
so what we now need to do is we need to
make migrations
so
python
manage dot py
make migrations
we then need to python manage dot py
migrate
and then we need to go python
manage dot py
create
super user
that will then allow us to create and
move this up a little bit that will then
allow us to create a super user see that
will default to bobby bob put that in
there anyway
bobby at did coding.com
password
it'll ask you twice it won't
look like you're typing but it will pick
up the keystrokes there you go so super
user created successfully so what we now
do is we'll go python
manage.py
run server
tell you what we haven't done we haven't
uncommented out
the urls so we we've wired in the um the
views
but we haven't uncommented these out so
i'll do that quickly so back on the urls
here um
remember we wired this main app into our
url com file so everything that appears
here are urls specific to main so path
is blank this will be our home page so
this will be
um
you know localhost port 8000 this will
be your index as view because we're
using class based views you must use
this dot as view if it was a function
based view you wouldn't need that name
is home so that's how we reference it in
the template so it'll be main
um
home that's how we would reference it
i'll show you when we work through that
shortly contact view same again we've
got um portfolio view it's portfolios
just pluralized um then we've got this
is important so this is the detail view
so this is portfolio slash slug okay so
the url will have the slug of that
object in it and that's how we're
capturing it in the detail view same
again for blog and blog slug okay so
they are the urls
so if we now
go back in our terminal
and we've got that up i should just be
able to double click that
there we have it
that is not
one second
just because i've got server running
on something else okay
there we have it right okay you just had
a sneak peek so i had a server running
on the previous project or the project
that i'm copying from so what you saw
there is what i built earlier okay so
nothing's working so we haven't got a
template there right we'd expect that so
if we go to admin which is the built-in
admin page
and then sign in with the user
credentials we've just added
there we have it okay so we've got the
authentication
models this is the one that we just
created okay
so we'll give me a
first name
we could have done that in the
terminal but there we go so we now got
an email first name last name
that signal
should have produced a user profile
which it has great so this is the user
profile now okay
so let's uh choose
avatar
so what we'll do is let's go into
desktop development i'll go into
this is the one i was playing with
earlier
media files avatar let's use that
title
is um
back end
developer
bio
this is just a demo bio
and
what we'll then do
is we will add a skill so this can be
django
and i'll put that on why not let's go
100
it's not a key skill this is my coding
skills
save
will have
html
and we'll have this as 95
save
we'll have
css
we'll have this as 90
save
and then what we'll do we'll add another
one which will be
javascript
uh let's just for
just change things up let's put 75
save let's have a key skill this time so
we'll have
people
person
we'll have uh it doesn't really matter
on a number there
key skill but what we'll do we will add
media files skills
open save
team
player i mean you can put whatever you
want in yours
this is just me building it out is a key
skill save
and we'll have um
self starter
we'll have that as key scale icon these
all come in their template by the way
all of these images
and cv so if i go into there these are
all ones that i've added earlier so
there we go
save so what i'm doing is i'm building
out the
the admin page so this is the benefit of
using django right so this built-in
admin page allows us to create so at any
point we could change the avatar at any
point we can change the bio so
um
i am
adding to the
bio
yeah so if you save it that will then
become the new bio so you don't have to
when you get this in a production
environment you don't have to go into
source code all you need to do is change
the back end that's the benefit of doing
this okay so
we've added
let's add a testimonial
so we'll choose choose a thumbnail
media files
use that one
name
bobby
roll manager
this
is a test
quote
that would do
save and add another or you know i'll
just quickly flash through this
name
bobby
two
manager
two
quote two
and i won't do this to all of them
because it'll be a waste of your time
bobby three
manager three and quote three
they're now the three objects so what we
can do we can make that inactive that
won't appear you see is active okay so
that wouldn't
be rendered on the front end but let's
keep that in there see the benefit there
so i've done user profile testimonials
skills they're all in there that's when
when we were adding them here
all you had to do click add and it adds
it to the skill because it's a many to
many field okay
again you can change these at any point
change that to you know or not in a key
change css to 2 92 for instance save and
that becomes 92 okay
media files let's add one of these
images
we'll add that
that's just a thumbnail from another
video that i've produced
random
image
save
contact profiles we don't need that
certificates we'll just add one
certificate shall we so now now
name
would be
um let's go
advanced
django
course
um
free code camp
description
this is
a
test
description
that'll do we won't add three
certificates you'll get the gist
and then what we need to do is add a
blog profile so this is where the rich
text editor comes into it okay
so author we can have bobby stearman
name we can have this as test blog
description
test description
and then what you can do is you can have
um
you can just have header two
this is a header
and whatever we put in here is what will
be rendered what you see is what you get
right so
this is
a
random
description and then this is what i
wanted to show you the the media file
so
let's go open up another browser okay
go back in the media files this here
will give us access to this url okay do
you get that that is the url of the
image we've just saved into our database
sorry into our static files okay if we
go into blog
and add an image to here
just toy around with this um it
sometimes won't render right on the
front end but if you toy around with the
rich text editor you can get its work
so if we add an image
the url just paste the url that we just
added in there
alt text test
image
admin main media oh what we're done
there that's not right i want that
let's copy that
there we go
right width we'll have these are these
are linked so if you just put 800
you can stick a border on there if you
want um we'll align it left
there's a whole bunch of other bits you
can do on there
link advanced so click ok
ok and then we'll choose an image this
will be the thumbnail for the image so
you can you can
pick the same one if you like is active
save
and for google's we'll add a portfolio
as well we'll do exactly the same again
right so now now
name is
test description test description
and then we'll have um
header 2
header
this is a description
this is the end
and in between that we will add an image
same again don't need to get too fancy
width would put 800 i think
stick a border on there we'll put four
on this time and left
okay choose a thumbnail
happy
days okay i think we've now got all of
the bits and pieces so that took a
little bit of jiggery pokery to get that
up and running in the back end but
that's all we now need to do see i
really i could could now um duplicate
these blog
these blogs so we've got um blog two
blog three whatever but it's
no biggie you can do that in your own
time i've just constructed the back end
in a way that i know this is going to
work and
just
if you're following along get this done
get three blogs get three portfolios and
it will look fantastic on the front end
so that is the back end basically done
what we now need to do is wire in the
front end
so
we have got the templates here
the directory for the resume is here so
what we need to do is we need our static
files so we will take these we'll copy
them
and we'll dump them into this is our
this is the project by the way
so new folder we'll call this
static and we will paste them so we
paste them in there okay
so they are all of us static files that
we need
go back into the resume and we then want
all of these so
keep your finger on control just select
all of them you don't need the license
to read me copy them
i'm going to add them to
main
templates main or paste
okay
they're all of the templates we now need
to wire them in okay if i just open one
of these now it's going to look terrible
right okay because it just doesn't know
where the static files are just doesn't
know what's going on okay because
they're now in a django project if i
open up them in the original
it'll work because that's just the way
it's wired up okay
so we don't need that let's close that
let's close that
let's close that
let's go back in a visual uh studio
right so these are now the um templates
that we've put together
we'll bring our terminal we don't need
to see the tone do you know what
i'll close that down for now we don't
need that so this is the
index file okay so um it's a standard
html file okay you've got a head
you've got body
and within that body you then got a
navigation so we've tried to be as
detailed as we can or helpful as we can
on the documentation of these html files
so this is the navigation bar this is
the content for this particular page
there's loads of sections
a bit further down actually let's just
hide them it'd be a lot easier a bit
further down we've then got
um the footer
okay and then we've got the scripts
these are the body these are the scripts
here okay nothing's going to work
because it's referencing files that
django just doesn't know where to find
them so if i was to render this this
index page so in fact let's go ahead and
do it so new terminal
work on uh
resume
demo
python
manage dot py
run server
and what i'll do i will
just
open up
that browser there right so it this is
this is the home page right so it's
found the index.html as per the views
it's found the template but it just
looks terrible it's because it doesn't
know what a css is it doesn't know what
a javascript is and all of the links are
all swift so we need to
load static files and we need to wire
all of this in so that's what we're
going to go and do and the way you do
this is we need a base html
so we will save index as
base dot html
and what we then need to do is create
another
directory in
main we'll call this
partials
and within
here we'll need a new file called
messages.html
we need another one in here called
nav dot html that'll be the navigation
element
new file and we'll call this
butter.html okay
so what we need to do is we need to
dissect up this html
so that
um
we can then use template tags so django
has a range of template tags that allow
you to easily
include other parts of html which you
need to do is just reference the path
so we'll go ahead and do that so right
at the top of the page
i need to open up my
other project here
and go to my base html
what you need to do you need to do this
most of them actually is
load static okay so that template tags
allows us to access static files which
are all the files that are now in this
directory here okay the css images
javascript
okay
we then go down we'll go down this all
the way from the top here so we've got
author which is decoding and james
granger design we've then got canonical
which we need to add
the context processor if you remember in
settings.py
where is it
so we added the contact processor here
but if you see here all
you always have access to request okay
so that's what we need to get hold of
here so it's
request
dot path okay so that is what you add in
canonical in fact i'm just going to copy
this across to save me messing about
we then have a link which is home
and then what we'll what we're using
here is a
template tag called url so relationship
home this is main so this is the app
main
and it's called home which is our index
page
we then in description these are all seo
tags really uh in the head of html file
this is how i always manage them i add a
block template tag
and i call it description and this
allows me to have a description of a
html page
in the actual
i'll show you what i mean in a second
and then i have another one for keywords
we've got the icon this little icon that
appears at the top of the web browser
and this is trying to find images
but it can't find images because images
um
where is what is the path for that we
need to reference the static file so
what we'll do we'll
link
there we have it so we're using the
static template tag we're loading static
at the top here
and then we're referencing the static
here so now we're looking in the static
directory
in a directory called images and we're
looking for icon.jpg
now
in static we don't we have images okay
so we'll be looking for icon which is
icon jpg okay so we'll be looking for
that that's what we're looking for
happy days and we've got static so
static again we're looking for css
we haven't got the path so we need to
reference static
and again with style css
so what we'll do is we will add
all of these
okay
and i always have a block uh template
tag here and i always call it extend
header this allows us to use css
specific to a certain page within that
template rather than having it loaded on
every page it's very very handy doing
that
okay we've then got the body
okay so what we're going to do here
is
i'm going to
copy that
and i'm going to remove
the header element so actually this is
what i'm going to do right okay so this
is the header the header remains the
same on all of these pages it's not like
we have a if a page is active then it is
highlighted we don't do that in this
template so you don't need to worry so
all of this here
can be cut
and can be dumped in the nav.html so
first off we'll have
load
static
and then we'll dump all of that
navigation in here okay
and then in the base html what we need
to do is
include it so we use another html tag so
it's include so we're now including main
so that's the main app partial sorry the
main directory partials nav.html so we
don't need all that html there it says
repeating ourselves we also need to add
some code which isn't in the template i
don't believe one second
no it's here right okay so there's an if
template tag i can add in here so this
is just some code that i use
occasionally
so if messages are rendered to the
html document so for messaging messages
so if this is a messages
dictionary or list so for each message
it will
render a script so this is javascript
there'll be a script it'll be an alert
so this will pop up with a little alert
at the top of the screen with the actual
message in that case it'll be thank you
for contacting us we'll get back to you
soon so that is our messages html if we
go back in a base
we can then import
or include messages into the body so it
always appears
in the html
then we need to do the same for all of
the content and all of the footer so
we go back to the footer stage foot
sorry the footer element we'll cut that
we'll dump that in footer
again load static don't forget to do
this
because you will run into an error
and we'll just uh tidy it up a little
bit bring it all back
oh
there we go save
and
the base we will then include that
copy
that's the footer and then with the
content what we're going to do is we're
going to have a block
so we'll have
block
content
and then we'll have
end block
okay so this is important right that
little block there is what we're going
to be using
when we render the index html so in the
index html it will contain all of this
um html the content essentially and we
will use a different con template tag in
index to extend base so index will then
be a combination of this html and the
base html okay so we will
cut that
we're going to index
we'll highlight oh we'll
so we'll go into index we'll highlight
everything and we'll paste it
and we will bring that back to tidy up a
little bit
there we have it
okay so now at the top of this page
we will need
a whole bunch of stuff which i'll show
you what we're going to do here
copy
and we'll paste that in
and i'll walk you through what i'm doing
section
gonna have one at the bottom there just
closing off the block
end block save and i'll just go from the
top right
okay so we're extending main base okay
so when we render the home page it's
looking for index html and it's slotting
in all of the information in this html
in the blocks that we're stating okay so
everything that's in block content will
be interjected or injected into this
block that's how it works okay so we'll
save that
actually before we move on let's just
update these remember it's looking for
javascript
those javascript files are in a static
directory so we will
add
the static
path
so this one becomes static js static.js
and then we add a footer here again it
allows us to add javascript to certain
html files that we don't necessarily
want to load
into the entire
template
okay or in all templates should i say so
this block content is what will be
rendered into
this block
okay
this block title is what will be
rendered into
where is it
i can't see what through the trees
did i even add that in there one second
i might not have done
oh i did i just didn't copy it across i
do apologize
so title will be block title okay so the
title here
anything we put here which we could put
did
coding
dash home
that will be rendered into
that block there okay
description that will be rendered into
that block and so on and so forth css if
we had a special css file that we wanted
on this particular page we'd add it here
we wanted javascript we'd add it there
content would have it here okay oh we've
got two start contents i don't want that
okay save
now the last thing we need to do
is we need to change all of the images
that this is referencing okay so this is
all looking for images here so what
we'll do we'll control h
and what we need to do is
static
images slash what that would do that
will replace all of everywhere it finds
speech marks images forward slash it
will replace with this code here which
is what we want there's nine occurrences
and then with the jpeg.jpg part of it we
will just go
jpg and we'll do that okay so we're
we're just we just want to replace it
all
save and i think we've also got an svg
yeah there we go svgs as well
dot svg
and replace all and if we save that i
think that's it i think that's all we
need to do for this
index page now we won't go through every
page well
so what we're doing for index is exactly
what we need to do for every single page
okay
so contact for instance and i'll show
you what i mean on contact and i won't
do all of the others because you know
you can do that yourself
i'll just copy those that could code
across from my other screen but i'll
show you what to do with contact in a
second but if i now it looks like it's
still the the
server is still up and running so if i
now update this it should there we go
it's looking for logo it can't find that
because we haven't changed or we haven't
um updated the images in the nav
and it's probably the same at the bottom
here we haven't done it in the footer
either
but everything else is rendering okay
okay except it's not linked to the back
end yet which would do that in a second
so footer i won't mess around with the
footer i'll literally just go a copy
paste
okay
so what i've done this is now the footer
so i've changed all of the links to
static you can see that static images
but then at the bottom here rather than
saying 2001 i've used another template
tag called now so that will always have
the most recent year so if when when we
hit the 1st of january 2022
um it would just show 2022 rather than
21. okay save that
nav will do exactly the same i will a
copy
again you will have access to this
project from github so don't worry too
much you'll have access to all of this
code
oh when i haven't changed that this
index.html needs to actually change to
url
main
home otherwise that link won't work but
it's looking for logo which is in the
static directory
and it's adding a url link to all of
this so the home link at the top of the
page will now be main home
portfolio will be portfolios blogs and
contact so that all of those links will
now work
go back into the browser update this now
works if you click it it will take you
back home if you click contact it will
take us to the contact page which looks
beautiful
so let's fix that quickly but as the
home page is working but we'll do
exactly the same as what we just did on
on the index page okay so all of this is
exactly the same we don't need that in
the contact page right the css can't
find it
we need to change all of that but save
me doing all of that again
all i really need is the contact section
right
content section
i don't need any any of the footer or
anything like that all i need is the
content
and if i go index and if i just copy
everything from here
up
go into contact
and dump it here
that should i don't need that
that can all go back a little bit i like
that to be nice and tidy
again exactly the same as index we're
extending the base html we're loading
static and then we can change all of
this but again this is why i like block
block
template tags so we can add whatever we
want in here
and that will be the new title for this
particular page okay css scripts
and this section here right so let's
focus on this a little bit because it's
quite important so contact us below
this is the form
that we've currently got
okay but we need to make this a django
form right so
what we need to do is add a method
equals and this is a post
and the action
is the url that we want to be
referencing so this is contact
so the reason we're putting that is
because in our urls
this is our url so it's contact okay
then we need to use because this is a
post not a get request or anything like
that we need in here
csrf token
that will add a hidden element with a
csrf token which uh will then work
then instead of these inputs
what we need
is
you know i'll just copy it across
but it's just form
and then reference the name
so if i
take those
if i dump those in here
okay so rather than being inputs we're
now rendering the form now the form is
contact form that's what we produced in
there in this forms.py and we're
bringing in the name field the email
field the message field
we need to change that to
message sorry that's an error on my part
and that is it that's all we need to do
but we need to close off the block which
don't forget to do that because there
will be an error
end block
that is the contact form done okay
don't need to do that all we need to do
is just double check
there we have it okay so technically now
if i was to put
bobby
stearman
bobby
did coding.com
message this is a
test message
now click submit hopefully
thank you we'll be in touch soon okay
that worked if we go into the database
and go into contact profiles there we
have it okay that's very very useful
that just means that you and this is
another reason why we're using django
any employer anyone who wants to contact
you using your contact form you have a
record of the timestamp and who it was
what the message was
in the database okay fantastic so let's
go back into
our project we've done index we've done
contact now let's focus on
let's go on to portfolio
same again don't need any of this gum
above content in fact all we need is
all of this copy
portfolio
paste that in there
we'll close the block off at the bottom
of the page oh no no we will once we
find the bottom of the content
scripts
i think that's that there no that's the
footer
don't want to furry that
end block
save okay so if we now just bring that
back a little bit
and that
doesn't really matter
um that's all good uh the only thing is
we've got some images who's here
um but i'm not gonna change all of those
that's not that's not a problem
um and we're not wiring this into the
back end just yet so i'm just making the
templates like they are so that's what
you would do to each of them but don't
get too carried away because you need to
add some django template tags like for
loops so we can actually render real
information so we'll do that but i'm not
going to do the detail for the one and
the um blogs i'll do that right at the
end i'll just copy and paste and walk
you through it but let's focus on the
index page
so at the minute
we have got uh this here so we've
changed this image so yeah it's showing
a picture of me but that's because that
image is in the static files what we
need to do is we want to reference the
avatar that we've saved against the user
profile and how you do that is
you don't need to reference static now
you just need to use
me which is in the context
context processor so that's me okay
but that's the user profile so we now
sort of use a model so we now go
user profile
dot
avatar which is the field and you want
the url of that
save
if we now go back into the home page
here go home that will still show it's
just now what it's doing
we go inspect
is now picking up um
media avatar so this is the actual image
that we saved against the profile rather
than the fileless in a static file which
is exactly what we want so i can now
change this
in a user profile to
another image
let's choose a file do you know what
i'll just stick that in there
and save if i go back in here
there we go it's not ideal but
it gives you an idea what we're doing
here so choose file go back in here go
into
avatar choose that and save again
bob's your uncle there you go happy days
so what we then need to do we need to
wire up all of this all of this
the csv file here and that's what we'll
do now okay so
hi i'm
you can go
me
dot
first name because this is the user
profile and then you can use a filter
called
title
now if i put bobby all lowercase in the
back end in the database that would
render a capital letter followed by all
lowercase
um hey
what would this be i think this is
title
me dot user profile
dot title i think
i won't go for all of these because
you'll get the gist of it right so
this will be
me dot
user
profile dot bio
so if we now go back in here and click
update there you have it so hi i'm bobby
a back-end developer this is just a
demo bio go back in the database
go back in the bio
dot dot dot dot dot loaded gobbledygook
press enter
or save
and update there we go that's how that
works it's really really handy
so if we then go into the button so
download so what we need here we want a
link to the csv file which is linked to
our user profile
so this will be me dot user profile
dot cv dot url
and that should now
because we've got a download attribute
if i click that it will then download my
csv
cv sorry you open it and that's the cv
that i've got on that profile okay which
is really handy
contact
that's currently saying contact html we
want that as a
see i hope you understand what i'm doing
here i'm just going through and i'm i'm
adding django template tags to
allow us to programmatically change this
and render information from a database
which is really good
really handy so that's
contact
now that link
i'm saving it as i go that link will now
take us to the contact page
okay and then what we'll do we'll
quickly do this and then i'll copy
everything across from my other screen
because it will take too long
so we'll go into um
[Music]
yeah we'll do this one in fact i'll copy
it you know what i'm going to copy
across and walk you through what i've
done
so
if i take everything from my index
now i go into here
and go everything from there so all of
that work i just done i'm just going to
copy and paste over anyway because it's
already done on the other screen
okay so
do you know what
let me go back quickly
before i do that because i want to show
you what we're actually replacing
so in this section no let's go into
this section here certificates right so
this is a slider so this is a slider
outer and then we've got a classic
certificate slider that's been
referenced in the javascript that's what
allows that javascript is what moves
these sliders across right so
that's what we're looking at
we've then got a swiper slide okay so
these are the elements so that's one
certificate that's two
and that's three okay
well i don't want those three i want the
ones that are in the database okay so i
don't want them to at all but i want
this
but rather than showing what it's got in
here i want it to render what's in the
database so to do that we would use a
for loop
for
c
in
sir tiff here cuts there we go so tiff
it cuts
and then we want an if
if c dot is
active
then render this if not don't render
anything right so we'll then close off
the if
and if
and i'll close off the four
and four okay so this is now a for loop
right
but what is rendering is a load of
goblin geek so what we want is
uh there's no link for the certificates
but you'd put you could if that was a
blog you'd put um the url template tag
so we want
this to be
c dots
just check the field
certificates i think at the bottom here
certificate so this could be title
that'll be
title
this would be
c dot date dot date
c dot
what is this going to be i
needed to
name title okay
so this is title
that'll be in this case for my example
would be free camp and then you have
this would be description
c dot description
okay
save so now rather than rendering
gobbledygook is rendering actually
something from the back end certificates
the reason i'm accessing that is because
it's in the context i added it in the
context in views okay so if you go here
that's what i'm accessing okay
so it's all active certificates
go back into index
and save that
i'm hoping i haven't buggered anything
up
no right so that's now showing one okay
because we've only got one in the
database but if i go to certificates and
click inactive save that won't render
anything yeah
so can you see what i'm trying to do
here
that's that's that so every refresh done
okay so i'm not going to go through and
do everything else because
you can see what we're trying to achieve
you need to add for loops and if
template tags to render the right
information against this template okay
so we'll go about and i will
add this content
here paste
save
and then render it
oh
emblem we've got two end blocks don't
want to end blocks save
go back
oh i've got two block contents as well
okay that's that's always fun
sorry i'm racing through i'm trying to
there we go let's delete that one save
that should now work
there we go right okay so this is now
all rendered
from the back end
so we're going to certificate if a kind
of skills
find our change
html to
98
save that
update 98
okay
and these these all change as well so if
i change that to 50 you'll probably see
what i mean actually
so i'll go 50
save
there we go okay
team players self starter it's looking
at different images certificates we've
got one in database featured work i've
got one testimonials i'll put three in
there if you remember
but if we
was to make one inactive for instance
save that
and update there we go we've only got
two in there okay
test blog
okay and if you were to click view all
what it will then do it will then take
you to the blog page but we haven't done
that yet okay so
i will quickly um add all of these
blog details so
copy if i go to blog details
paste
so what we're doing here blog deep oh
actually and we'll do a blog
copy and we're going to blog just the
normal blog list page
save and if we go and render this now it
should look good there we go okay so
this is rendering my one blog that i've
got so this is a list view if i added
another blog it would appear there it
looks really really good so if i click
on this it'll open up the blog details
view
okay and right okay that doesn't that
didn't render too well so
this when i say you need to mess around
with the ck editor because it does um
some reason it renders some of the
information incorrectly but that's fine
you know this is just
playing playing with the information
there
so we're going to blogs
blog profile
what i do is i just
i wonder what that looks like that might
help
this is the end right you can see what
i've done there i've just added some
bits it's because the image is probably
too small for the for the actual screen
if i was to make it a bit bigger
let's go back in there make this
uh image properties
change that to what a thousand let's
have a look
okay
save
there we go it's starting to do
something different now okay so
tinker play around with it what you see
is what you get with a rich text editor
but it just allows you to design a
different blog so all of your blogs
don't need to look the same but you can
use the same template which is great and
a really good benefit of using django
here
so if i now open this all we've done is
in the blog detail page
we have got yeah the object.name author
so this has always been pulled through
from the back end
um but this is what's important okay so
the object.body if i was to remove safe
all it renders is raw html
like that so this is the html that the
which textedit is creating but because
we're using the safe
template filter it actually renders the
html into something tangible that we can
actually see and it's rendered well on
the front end so if i change that now
back to safe
save
there we go and i'll quickly just for
google's i will change
the details page copy
this one where is it there we go
save
portfolio
copy and portfolio
save so if i now go into here i'm going
to portfolio there we go and clicking
portfolio that
is again it's because the image that
we've got in here portfolio
uh let's change this image properties so
let's put that as a thousand and that'll
probably work now
there we go uh again have a tinker
uh again but then look if we were to
mark this as inactive
and portfolio it won't work okay
um to be honest that might still work
yeah you
you could also put in the uh view that
if
that if the query so if the object is
marked as inactive then you can do a
render redirect so you can redirect back
to the portfolios list so it will never
show
a url but i haven't done that in this
instance so that is it that is the
template done
so we have now got a digitized
resume
that is entirely
um
that is entirely made in django and we
can change every single key element of
this resume without having to change any
of the
core any of the um
code in the background so
that's brilliant
that is more or less the end of this i
don't i will just recap right so
what have we done we've just digitized a
resume right so we've built a whole
project in django we've digitized our
word or pdf see it cv or resume and
we've put it online so you would make
this website you put it in a production
and then you'll be able to send that
link to an employer that will help you
stand out in a crowd the good thing is
because we've used django we are able to
use the built-in admin page and we are
able to create read update and delete
all elements of the resume so you never
have to change the source code now that
that is fantastic right so let me change
it so you can actually see me again
okay so that that is really really good
i have really enjoyed putting this video
together
again my name is bobby stearman and i am
from did coding
please subscribe to my channel i do
videos like this all of the time before
i close the video off i just like to say
thank you to my colleague james granger
who helped me put this template together
he designed it and without him we
wouldn't be able to give it away for
free again it can be found on my github
which is github.com bobby dash decoding
slash decoding underscore resume
underscore
template
thank you very much for watching i have
enjoyed creating it i hope it's useful
and i'll see you in the next video thank
you bye